alors jazz manouche à conquis de
nombreux émules et ils ont sorti en
février à 4e album intitulé Mambo Jumbo
une tour de pige un tout nouveau
spectacle que vous vous aurez la chance
de voir notamment le 14 juin à la
batterie à Guyancourt voici les Doigts
de l'Homme dans le kiosque les Doigts de
l'Homme comme une claque dans ta face
les doigts de l'homme c'est devenu un
quintet avec l'intégration de Antoine
Gérard à l'accordéon et puis sinon ben
moi je suis Olivier je suis guitariste
et le fondateur du groupe
le disque qu'on a fait juste avant 1910
c'était le discommage à Django on
voulait pas en faire 50 on voulait en
faire un c'était celui-là et je trouve
qu'il a bien fonctionné voir mieux que
les autres du coup moi je voulais pas
perdre mon fil c'est à dire rester sur
un projet de création
et puis je voulais pas qu'elle
comparaison avec ce disque justement
1910 j'ai eu envie de changer
complètement l'esthétique c'est vrai que
l'accordéon ça l'avantage de nous sortir
des cordes donc ça c'est pour l'aspect
purement raisonné mais il y a aussi que
l'accordéon c'est un instrument
polyphonique qui permet des valeurs
longues beaucoup d'espace et comme c'est
les guitar manouche et des sons très
secs très donc on a tendance un petit
peu à remplir à charger tout ça ça avait
plein de plein d'intérêt pour moi
tu vois il y a une quinzaine d'années à
peu près il y a une vague manouche qui a
commencé à pouvoir revenir comme ça et
plein de gens se sont engouffrer là
dedans et comme d'habitude l'instrument
média a commencé un petit peu à tout
mélanger
tu vois Bénabar ça devenait de la
musique manouche il y avait une volonté
de dire cette musique là on l'aime on la
respecte et voilà la vision qu'on en a
quoi pas forcément pour démontrer quoi
que ce soit mais
en tout cas je pense que le message par
la force des choses était celui-là ouais
qu'on n'est pas effectivement des
touristes dans dans cette musique
même boum littéralement en anglais c'est
un peu c'est charabia ou le vocabulaire
propre à un corps de métier genre celui
du médecin
mais le sens que ça avait là c'est c'est
qu'en fait c'est le premier album où
tout le monde compose donc tout le monde
amène de la matière avec son vocabulaire
propre j'ai l'impression quand même que
c'est homogène
cette différence elle est là par essence
parce que aucun de nous n'est manouche
donc d'entrer on a le choix tu sais
c'est comme quand tu vas visiter un pays
étranger quoi tu as le choix entre
rester ce que tu es et le confronté à ce
que sont les autres autour de toi ou
chercher à tout prix à t'assimiler moi
c'est un truc que j'aime pas faire parce
que je trouve que c'est une manière de
se renier quoi avant de faire de la
musique manouche j'ai fait plein
d'autres trucs on a tous fait plein
d'autres musiques je trouve dommage de
faire table rase de tout ça sous
prétexte que on a envie de rentrer dans
cette case là donc par la force des
choses on laisse on laisse nos
influences s'exprimer naturellement et
puis du coup ça fait un projet qui est
effectivement est de plus en plus
éloigné de la musique manouche même
puisque là on s'est dit allez ça fait 10
ans on fait ce qu'on veut quoi
l'univers est resté très acoustique il y
a un choix plus clair qui a été fait sur
les guitares moi j'ai essayé pas mal de
choses dans le passé avec plus ou moins
de succès mais en tout cas j'ai toujours
voulu essayer des choses nouvelles quoi
là les choses nouvelles elles ont pas
été tentées sur le sur la diversité de
l'instrumentation tu vois on est resté
tous les cinq tout au long du disque il
y a pas d'instruments autres que ceux du
Quintess quoi et mais par contre sur les
orientations musicales il y a des choses
qui partaient clairement plus Amérique
du Sud d'autres vraiment Europe de l'Est
en fait la case manouche est restée en
toile de fond sur tout le disque mais il
y a vraiment des morceaux on en est très
très loin quoi
merci beaucoup merci à vous
et maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction
vous avez dit plastoc mais le plastique
peut aussi être chic c'est tout du moins
la question que pose le musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans
le cadre de sa nouvelle exposition
plastique plastoc jusqu'au 23 décembre
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir
l'évolution de cette matière et son
utilisation à travers le temps mais
alors quels sont les liens qui unissent
le plastique et le design
plastique plastoc c'est en fait
l'histoire d'une rencontre un peu
improbable entre le plastique et le
design dans la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle au moment où
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sort de terre
alors je dis improbable parce qu'en fait
on a on associe très vite au plastique
l'idée de jetable de banal de pas cher
de mauvaise qualité tandis que le design
pour nous c'est plutôt le luxe la
créativité les matériaux nobles et
ensuite certes et designers s'en
emparent mais on n'a pas l'impression
que ça révolutionne complètement la
façon de voir le plastique de nos jours
on a toujours ses idées reçues sur le
plastique ce que l'expo va un peu
démonter
illustrer d'objets fonctionnels ou
d’œuvres de designer le plastique est
présenté ici à travers trois grandes
périodes créées au début des années 50
pour imiter les matériaux les plus
nobles comme l'ivoire ou la nacre le
plastique est très vite employé pour son
côté pratique produit à grande échelle
il envahit nos maisons et révolutionne
même nos modes de consommation
lorsque les designers s'en emparent au
cours des années 60 l'objectif devient
alors plus esthétique et créatif place
aux tendances colorées et aux formes
improbables
depuis les années 80 des bouleversements
économiques et des changements de
mentalité poussent désormais les
industriels designer à produire des
plastiques intelligents des plastiques
qui changent de couleur qui se déforment
et surtout qui se recyclent le plastique
a-t-il encore de l'avenir
on pourra aussi faire des plastiques bio
qui sont faits à partir de particules de
chambre par exemple donc ils se recycle
encore plus facilement
et puis le plastique pourra être utilisé
dans beaucoup d'innovations
technologiques
au-delà d'une exposition didactique les
visiteurs peuvent trouver des espaces
participatifs pour manipuler de la
matière découvrir des procédés de
production ou encore proposer leurs
idées pour un concours d'objectifs en
parallèle une exposition temporaire
autour du mobilier gonflable est
également à visiter jusqu'au 27 juillet
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
votre cours de tai-chi les machines
musicales jouées par Jean-Pierre Drouet
Louise clavier seront sur la scène du
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines le 17 mai
tandis que les enfants pourront se
régaler avec un petit tableau de ciel
les 21 23 et 24 mai à la Maison de la
poésie de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
enfin les familles pourront se bidonner
le 21 mai avec la comédie d'Isan de
mariage présenté à la salle Jacques Brel
à Montigny le bretonne des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation des salsa
cantinoises sur Internet aux adresses
qui s'affichent et n'oubliez pas que
tous les mardis sur le
www.qiosque.ski.fr vous pouvez gagner
des places de spectacle alors jouer
gagner amusez-vous à bientôt